i always forget at one point you were
the most subscribed channel yeah yeah
two separate times two separate times
yeah it's like a three month period and
a eight month period or something i
forget how was that like how was it at
at one point you were at the top it was
it was really cool was there pressure
though i bit there was al there was
definitely pressure and it it um
it filtered the way that i looked at
everything that i did yeah
for better or worse there was there was
the good of like ooh everything that i
make has some kind of value i should put
a lot of my time and energy in this
because i know a lot of people are going
to see it and it really pushed me to
constantly be pushing myself outside my
boundary or out of my comfort zone right
because i knew that it would you know
not literally pay off but it would pay
off in the sense that a lot of people
would see it and potentially be able to
enjoy it yeah but then on the opposite
side of that there was a lot of getting
in my own head about
um the pressure and how i have to live
up to this and then you're also always
seeing comments of people saying like
how is this whatever and it's a lot of
um filtering it out to be like
it doesn't matter that some people don't
like this it's not for them
but it would get in my head of like oh i
need to i need to be better and it was a
lot of like this this pressure
you were mentioning earlier about how
obviously when you started you got the a
deal from a company yeah i imagine when
it was starting to ramp up and get to
like number one most subscribed you're
probably getting offered all sorts of
weird and predatory stuff and just
probably just the most stressful company
meetings ever
dude we had
we had someone show up to my house it
was i was living with my mom obviously
like in just like our small little tiny
house outside yeah
sacramento california and there was this
predator i i don't want to call him
predatory but there's this guy came up
in a business suit and he's like oh god
knocked on the door my mom was like
there's someone outside oh no
so ian and i walk out and we're like
uh
what is up and he's like oh um i got
your address because i saw that you just
registered for a business and it was
marked under this address so i figured i
would just show up and tell you a few
things about like what you could be
doing what the [ __ ] how you could be
monetizing this and i was like
i was 18. so i didn't know and it was my
first time with like any kind of um fame
or right now i didn't know that this was
a [ __ ] up thing to do so i entertained
it and
come on in yeah would you like some tea
i drew the line there
there was no invitations inside yeah um
but luckily he was a vampire and he
could not enter without me uh
no so he
he was like okay so your pokemon theme
song music video
[Music]
like it's this epic cinema a piece of
piece of cinematic work uh and he was
like it has three million views
so think about it this way i could get
you sponsored by coca-cola oh my god and
if if you get a thousand dollars per
million it's three thousand dollars in
your pocket like that and i was like
first of all
do you actually know
do you have any contacts with coca-cola
and he just started listing all and i
realized immediately that he was full of
[ __ ] he was trying to make some kind of
a connection and he was like but like
the mcdonald's and i was like dude so he
clearly didn't know what he was talking
about luckily uh he only showed up one
other time after that yeah
only one out of the time
one other time i was like mom when that
guy shows up again you just ignore that
the bad man in the zoo leaving
um
but
luckily we were uh i mean we were not
very smart but we were smart enough to
know that that did not feel right yeah
yeah right yeah yeah because we were
talking to like sean jacksepticeye like
a few weeks ago and how back in like the
early days of youtube there was just no
boundaries between fans and like the
creators so fans would literally show up
at his house oh yeah yeah yeah did it
happen to you a lot oh absolutely
yeah yeah so uh ian and i ended up
renting this place together um he and i
and we had another roommate with us too
and um we lived there for i think four
years and that's when our videos were
really really really starting to become
popular like right
2009 to 2011
is so many ridiculous stories of like
mobs of people
like i'm trying to edit in my editing
room and and there's like i just hear
like people running around the house and
like laughing and like looking through
our trash
it was people did not know boundaries
how did we find out where you live
because we were really stupid
so like all blame is on us but right we
would just shoot outside of our house
yeah
our address would be in it
like they knew exactly how to find us
and we uh because this was also during
the time where you were doing the mail
unboxings on the screen yeah yeah so i
bet like that also came into it as well
right yeah i remember like you know back
uh back way back when i used to watch
this mail in boxing oh yeah those are my
favorites dudes i love them
i think
at that time it was something so unique
because obviously you know you know big
massive celebrities would be getting
this kind of stuff but it was the first
time that like a normal person could
just watch somebody receive all sorts of
weird [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah like this is
so weird yeah it really did show you the
scope of like how strange yeah
the common person can be with the items
that they choose to send yeah yeah yeah
and the drawings that they choose to
draw
that must have been weird oh yeah yeah
what was some like the weirdest stuff
you ever lost i have some very good
go-to's for that don't you worry okay
yes we got we got ziploc bag of dead
bees
[Music]
i want to know
how did they collect those they might
not have been bees maybe they look like
bees i did not examine enough to know
for sure
we have a slightly smaller we have a
slightly smaller thinner bag of nail
clippings
oh
yeah everyone did you receive [ __ ] as
well at one point um
we received stuff that smelled like [ __ ]
that we never ventured
we definitely had uh boxes and we
received so many boxes that we would
sometimes just throw in our garage and
they would sit in the humidity and
it would be months before we get to it
and people thought it was so funny that
they would send us
uh sandwiches
and these sandwiches would just rot
and oh like the food fight stuff i don't
i don't know why but it became a thing
and the bags the ziplock bags would you
know inflate with the gases from these
things
and then the scent would just permeate
throughout our entire house
yeah you'd throw away the boxes once
they were kind of um you could see like
patches kind of sopping wet or oily or
greasy
um but that quickly was like it's
probably about time to stop uh receiving
the mail like it was fun it was a great
time period how long did you guys do
that for i think we did it for like
three or four years
and by the end it was years of stuff
just built yeah towers and towers a man
oh god
every now and then you probably get
something really [ __ ] cool you're
like yes yeah yeah we received some
really cool [ __ ] oh man lots of lots of
used video games and then i would just
take them all to gamestop and be like
use video games
and then they'd be like a hundred
dollars credit i was like two games i
actually won
that's so big
not like the the eight copies of of the
of the
nintendogs rip-offs of like puppies and
like all these weird like ponies and
cats
[Music]
so many weird games that i would never
be interested in playing i was like i
can convert these into games i want to
play
yeah just giving junk yeah just trying
to get rid of it
well we we were given um a lot a lot of
stuff that we were given were um
just like
people are looking for things to send
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna send you
something yeah and they didn't want to
spend money on just sending because they
didn't even know if we would see it
right there's no guarantee we didn't
even know if we would see it in fact
some of the things i hope you know it's
probably better if we didn't see half
the things that we did so
um but people would send us just old
stuff that they wanted to throw away
yeah because i wanted a garage sale or
something right it was like old shirts
that had not been washed in years hours
oh yeah because to them it was probably
just like yo that's my shirt in the
video yeah yeah yeah so then we had to
start being really selective about the
things that we showed we had to stop
showing the [ __ ] stuff the dead stuff
the body the human body the human body
the the anything that came from a human
body was no longer making it in the
videos yeah
yeah we realized that we were
encouraging it and then we also
accidentally encouraged people to send
us money because we had one video where
someone um a few people sent us like one
dollar bills so he's like oh we got ten
bucks and like it was kind of a joke and
then uh then we had to make oh we got a
hundred bucks and it was like we need to
stop showing money all together yeah and
we realized that anything that we showed
was a direct call for people to send us
more of it right so eventually we had to
stop showing the weird stuff or the
really grandiose stuff because we didn't
feel comfortable with either right yeah
someone might feel bad if you show off
like something really amazing and
they're like oh and i guess
from like mexico sent me this like
shitty little keyboard
and a lot of people were saying really
sentimental right right handwritten
things that we could never
actually like if i wanted to read every
one of those and i really wish i could
because they were they were so heartfelt
like it would have been a full-time job
to do that yeah nothing else yeah yeah
which is a great problem to have yeah so
you mentioned like you know you were one
like pretty much one of the first
creators to get paid for doing what you
do on youtube when did you start to
realize oh this is this is like serious
now this is like gonna get big
i mean it depends like there are so many
different uh levels of big like at that
point i already felt like it was a big
thing right right when we because i was
like we're one of the first people to
get paid on this platform that i foresee
is having longevity yeah yeah yeah um
but
in terms of like
i don't know it was a little bit dicey
though so that was 2007 and then four
years later i didn't really know what
the fate of youtube was gonna be yeah
and we had an offer from a company which
ultimately um you know their name ended
up being defy right and they offered us
then to
buy our company for stock it's totally
great idea
well you've talked about this a lot in
your video yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um obviously didn't end up being worth
anything so how did they pitch it to you
in a way that you both were like yeah
this is a [ __ ] great idea let's do it
like how did that like happen
yeah you know and it is a complicated uh
i mentioned this too because because you
know
uh
that like the state of youtube in 2011
it felt really like we didn't know where
it was going was that before or after
the google plus thing they tried to
shove in
no that was 20. that was when i first
started so that was like 2014. yeah yeah
that was ages okay okay
google plus is when google tried to do
facebook and oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was just a [ __ ] show
i think i think it lasted like a year
and they caught up maybe and then they
were like now we're getting rid of it
youtube has been constantly it
especially in earlier days it did seem
like it was like what the [ __ ] is it it
was it felt very fragile for a while
yeah right yeah so so they presented it
to us as
um you know we're gonna take all the
website smosh.com stuff off your plate
because i was doing all of that myself
because you know i was actually i
actually made money before we started
getting paid on youtube by designing
websites for people right
and that's how we i was able to fund a
lot of things and you know side tangent
the uh our videos actually started
getting we made like two lip sync videos
before the pokemon
before before we found out about youtube
and um i i hosted it on my own website
yeah and yeah
there was because there was no website
like youtube to host it on yeah yeah
yeah yeah and uh
i created a little thing it was a again
it was an iframe a copy you copy paste
there and when you paste that to your
page i had instructions and everything
when you copy paste it's your myspace
page it put the video there and then it
also had instructions to copy and paste
for someone else like that was how i
designed this like
uh like copy paste viral kind of thing
all right and uh i didn't know how well
that was doing with the two lip sync
videos it's so weird to say that uh that
we did beforehand
uh but i did get the the bill i did see
the bill and it was a couple hundred
bucks you know and i didn't know how to
convert that into how many views is this
getting but i knew it was getting a lot
of views or else i wouldn't have to pay
a couple hundred dollars for bandwidth
on videos right um so you actually used
to have to pay
yeah bandwidth before youtube offered
the service so we found out about
youtube by me doing a search for one of
the videos i found that someone else had
uploaded it to youtube and i sent them a
message i was like hey this video thank
you so much for uploading it here uh we
want to upload it ourselves do you mind
removing it and they said yeah
absolutely so
we created our channel smosh was still
five letters still available yeah yeah
and uh that was the beginning of that
damn uh
shoot i forgot where we were going we
were going with
okay okay yeah okay i got off inside the
engine because i was talking about how i
designed the website
trash station
just don't worry we're getting right in
right yeah oh yeah seamless um
so they came to us and
they were like we will take care of the
website so you no longer have that
stress to deal with because every week
the website was crashing and i was
figuring out how to
you know keep it up and i they they had
this huge plan of all the things that
they were capable of and how they had
the infrastructure to allow us to do all
of our dreams so they asked us what do
you want to do with this company if you
could make this company anything what
would it be and we had these huge lofty
goals they said we got all of that on
lock we have the infrastructure we have
the investors we can make this happen
right uh and they offered us a certain
amount of money in stock yeah it sounded
really good more money than i thought
that you know i would ever see in my
life before that
so i was like that sounds great
obviously this company is eventually
going to go public that's how they work
right yeah i did not know
my lawyer did not tell me that that's
not always the case the people that we
had surrounding us that um were
authority figures in some way to us on
the situation did not break down the
details and how that doesn't always
happen and how it's that's actually a
huge risk yeah yeah um so
they bought full ownership and they paid
us um
in
yearly you know annual salaries right
and they had this structure set up where
it was like this year yeah it's pretty
shitty salary but next year it's a it's
an okay salary but by year four you're
going to love your salary so did that
happen it it it did eventually go out
that way and i was i was uh pretty
comfortable with it i was like we are
making a good
uh salary here like we what do we really
have to complain about and i guess
they're doing a lot of the
stuff that you used to have to do and
they're looking at things and managing
it but then also imagine as a youtuber
it's probably quite difficult to give
that control it was too because i did
give that control away and everything
was not how i would have done it
i ended up working double time to teach
them how to do the things but then they
were rehiring in the way that bigger
companies work is like you're never just
building a one-on-one relationship with
someone who like you teach them once and
they know and they keep going with that
thing and it's just a thing that happens
now it's like yeah no you're re-teaching
and re-teaching and re-teaching until
it's like okay let's abandon the website
and then it was like me abandoning a lot
of the things that i
had a dream of growing because i was not
able to keep that up and also do the
videos yeah i had to figure out where to
put my time